in a few hours from now president Trump
will be firing up a crowd in Pensacola
Florida at a make America great again
rally he's about to leave Washington to
make his way there and in the tweet this
morning he said we have done so much in
so short a period of time and yet we are
planning to do so much more critics hate
to give mr. Trump any credit but he has
been delivering on his promises to the
American people he pledged to make the
economy great again and today a new
Labor Department report shows our
economy added 228 thousand jobs last
month the president promised tax cuts
for Americans a sweeping overhaul was
passed by the GOP lead House and Senate
he kept his word earlier this week to
officially recognize Jerusalem as
Israel's capital meanwhile fewer illegal
immigrants are trying to sneak into our
country border arrests are down and we
are finally crushing Isis is anyone else
tired of all this winning justice look
at his face he's at perma-grin now did
that be the way they are right that
[Laughter]
[Music]
actually had a story the other day it
said Donald Trump keeper of promises
they're shocked because he's not a
topical politician he's a man of action
he's a businessman so he's actually
following through I mean the economy's
humming Isis we're bombing the hell out
of Isis and Mexico is still gonna pay
for the wall I do and listen note the
he'll be judged on the economy I think
17-year record low on joblessness and
it's it's widespread I think four point
seven percent Hispanic unemployment in
the Obama economy in the last year a
thousand manufacturing jobs were being
lost each month I think the Trump
economy of so far has created a hundred
and fifty nine thousand manufacturing
jobs that's very very strong and then
you know internationally tearing up all
the treaties getting out of all the bad
trade deals you know we heard about Isis
and then he's fulfilling a lot of
promises to the Conservatives he made
Gorsuch packing the court with great
conservatives and I think still
maintaining a strong
connections to the people the Forgotten
men the Forgotten men and women of this
country defending the flag defending our
history our military our Second
Amendment and you know he does these
rallies which he's preparing for it now
it maintains the relationship this is
such a auspicious day for Jesse Walker
gonna make America great again movement
so he's in the speech tonight people are
enthusiastic about it this is coming on
a high note for the president with a lot
of good accomplishments that he can tell
can you add or improve those
accomplishments one more yeah
what a strange phenomenon this
presidency has been we have we have a
large part of the country who believes
that we are in a Mad Max sequel and then
the rest of us are like every day is
NASCAR it is incredible it's really an
exercise in mass delusion based on
confirmation bias that there's so many
people we're all looking at the exact
same thing but every third two camps
that are seeing two different things and
I do believe that the people that are so
entrenched in their negativity they're
like they're if they're led largely by
emotion and they can't let go I think a
lot of the confirmation bias is fueled
by an emotional reaction to Donald
Trump's are we saved by my notes here
the key is to separate the psychological
effects of Trump from the practical
results of his actions that's how you
that's how you're gonna end up judging
this guy his in-your-face personality is
always gonna salt the wounds of people
who don't like him like tonight will
salt the wounds of some people but will
indulge the pleasures of another but the
fact is if you set what we did in the
opening here was we listed two practical
results of his actions devote and were
divorced from the psychological effects
of his personality and when you do that
you have to admit this is a phenomenon
it is this is a consequential leader
all right so Dana and what do you think
about like what should the president
focus on today but you know obviously
there's some accomplishments to
highlight and focus on for the people
well the first year of any presidency is
usually the most consequential because
you have all the juice from the
he's behind you I think that the what
you're talking about the two viewpoints
was that was true during the Obama years
group I agree yeah and so this is not
just that phenomena and if this were a
different network at the end of Obama's
first year they could have had the exact
same list cuz it's just how you spin it
another network tonight might say here's
all the things that Trump has failed to
do or that have all the all that
basically the headwinds that are hard
for him but I do think that if he's if
he wants to look at things that he could
tick off the box these things are all
happening it's really good and I think
you know the Obama team might say well
look he had theirs today was 86
consecutive months of job growth hmm
okay well obviously he's only been in
office for 11 months so these things
compound each other on themselves and
economies cycle but there is no doubt
that the consumer confidence really shot
up the deregulation effort is certainly
really consequential the other thing we
didn't talk about here is something that
is really having an impact and that is
the pulling back of all of those
executive orders that President Obama
put in place because they weren't solid
so because they weren't solid he's able
to walk them back that also has helped
fuel good economic things there is a job
there is a campaign promise that he made
that he has not kept that I think that I
understand why politically he did not
and that is on the top tax rate for this
tax refrain he campaigned on a 33
percent top tax rate and that was
actually all the Republicans ran on that
together I understand the concern that
it would look like maybe he was giving
the rich too much of a pass including
himself so that's why you know it
creeped up and then that's the way you
have the individuals paying more on in
some cases and then the corporations
getting this rate and the math is really
hard to do I think politically it
doesn't matter they're always going to
say that he's doing everything just for
the rich so in order for a good economic
growth policy he should just be able to
work with the Congress when they go to
conference next week and actually
fulfill that campaign promise because it
will fuel the economy more you know
goose it a little bit Oh watch your
mouth I don't know it would be on the
blog's okay but so Jesse you would
probably agree with that point actually
yeah I mean we need top tax relief badly
he campaigned on it you said it was
gonna be Reaganesque it's more Mondale
esque
and like you said he's gonna get
criticized for it anyway why not do it I
think the reason they did it because it
has to be a 1.5 trillion dollar deficit
virtual deal and then you need 60 votes
in the Senate I know I'm boring
everybody with that but not really could
have been a lot more aggressive I feel
bad for one floor now just you know just
crush it I don't it's not hard to crush
it I mean it's like it's like what Greg
said where the who pasted this from the
White House in the Communications Office
I mean you know you we report you decide
what are the American people saying
about Trump his approval rating down
around 32% of the rating is no let me
finish
let me just this was Obama you guys
would be jumping on the table like your
friend me just tell you something 30
look what about the tax plan that you
guys are bragging about oh gee whiz
Gallup 29 percent approval most
Americans think this is a terrible deal
a giveaway you say oh what he's going to
get criticized anyway no the government
giving out big corporations and the rich
are getting their money back but the
working this is what goes to Dana's
point Dana said well they're just going
to say anyway that you know you just
give away to the rich but actually the
promise was that the middle class or
working-class America would benefit from
this tax plan and that's just I think
the numbers are pretty good on that so
and I think even today when we look at
the job growth you know everybody oh
this is great wait a second do you
realize the job growth this year is
slower than it was last year oh goodness
here January from Trump's election it's
actually better you know what calendar
yeah
I think I think you have to understand
it's not the Grinch that's stealing your
coal here it's reality
let's back the echo-chamber is getting a
little thick here I think even in terms
of wages which is something he said oh
I'm gonna improve wait what about this
Jesse workforce participation remember
we said Oh Obama has low unemployment
but you know a lot of people aren't
participating the workforce because
they're discouraged workforce lack of
participation actually because that is
something that the Congress the
Republican leaders and the president
have said they want to tackle next year
and part of workforce participation is
the amount of people who are on benefits
that are actually able-bodied but they
would lose money if they ended up going
to work and that's why the wage pressure
issue could get better because if you
don't have enough workers you're gonna
have to pay people more and then they're
gonna try to get people back to work
that well here's the thing a lot of
these people are getting older they're
retirees and guess what if you said that
when I said that a year or two ago
everybody so that's pretty true that's
ridiculous but here's the bottom line
that I would say to you guys
forget the Democrats just look at the
Republicans guess what Republicans have
a lower opinion of Trump today than they
did in fact
all you're doing is shutting polls
wasn't a good test it wasn't an
indicator
well he's not only person he's running
against this your first year is almost
always your most consequential and then
you will continue to try to drive
forward it gets harder in an election
year to try to actually get bigger
things done that's why you try to get
them done as much as you can and that's
why they try to get the tax reform done
and the sequencing being trying to do
infrastructure and welfare next year no
sorry in border security you know what
also is helping him is the media
creating a monster by combining various
visuals and stereotypes in fear they've
kind of turned Trump into something else
like an orange phantom he is almost like
a super villain
and that's actually added to his appeal
I think I mean I think if the media had
not exaggerated the the physical and
comic for
Martians and his mannerisms said that
such a degree I think you would be
having a harder time well until this
week was anyone making fun of his
mannerisms yeah SNL's entire is the
numbers of me with the hate for
themselves do they not Jesse for me as a
former prosecutor I love the fact we've
got a 25% decrease in illegals crossing
the border 40% surgeon number of
deportations in 2017 this to me has a
direct pivotal impact on crime in in the
across the country and especially in
areas that are really challenged like
California and border states to me this
has been as very good news and he's
improving on it and only if we can build
the wall correct